welcome back to new rock stars we
finally got a peek at eternals but these
folks were in the mcu and since the
beginning but they didn't help
at all throughout any of the movies i
feel like if we're gonna look at them as
kind of like gods they should have been
there from the get the jump
uh i'm jessica clements this is rogue
theory the show where we wildly
speculate about the things we love with
me today
to go on these tangents and rants is
fellow new rockstars
mt hey jess what's going on hi baby how
are you doing
i'm feeling good because i'm about to
talk about some nerd stuff with some
pretty amazing
nerd people some fine hot nerd people
and talking about fine hot nerd people
uh the uncle of new rock stars my baby
boy tommy bechtel
and last but not least welcome back to
the show
uh formerly nerdwire currently the host
of whitneyvision
catch it here whitney van landingham uh
my third baby
my third baby how are you doing oh my
gosh i got adopted this is amazing i've
been waiting my whole life just
lingering at that orphanage
oh good this entire show today is to see
who which was my favorite child with the
best theories
okay this and again
as i say all the time when i'm hosting
rogue theory it's not a competition
but it is a competition
i am a i'm a competitive person no one
loves playing board games with me
and we're going to get into it starting
right now
so let's get into it let's get into
eternals though eternals was there the
entire time let's talk about
so we just got this last footage right
the last should we see with eternals
leaves us with some pretty big open
questions like if these characters
were here in the background of the mcu
what have they been doing this entire
time
uh what past mcu events could the
eternals be connected to
if they haven't been helping out behind
the scenes why step into the spotlight
right now so firstly let's get into
what the hell are the eternals doing why
they come back or
why did they come out of the shadows i
guess
if i may uh go a little rogue here i am
wondering
oh uh i think that we're gonna get
another thing that marvel
likes to do where these people these
eternals these
these beings just didn't know they were
the eternals for a while
something happened to them where their
brains were
controlled or their memories were i mean
we saw that in captain marvel we saw
that in juan division
this is something the mcu loves to do
how do you solve a problem of why
aren't these people involved in bigger
catastrophes why wasn't carol danvers
helping when the chitauri were invading
because she didn't know who she was you
know she was just
okay we have all these we have all these
uh
these these uh cases of this happening
in marvel properties
i think they're just gonna like
something's gonna happen when when iron
man re-snapped everyone back
or snapped thanos out of existence
something the
radiation had awoken all of these
eternals and they were like oh
we're awesome we should have helped
everybody got wiped off the lake
the world for five years dude i just
love too that it's
it's not like they were doing something
else like really important
they were taking a little snooze they're
snoozing around
and it's like bro you couldn't have
woken up from your gosh dang
there for a second for like a second
like even just like
it must have been a really good nap must
have been a solid quality of the map
listen because they're the eternals they
hypothetically could have gone to the
70s gotten some really really really
dope lemony quaaludes and just
rode those lewds straight through the
infinity war
not knowing what the hell happened
that's probably what happened honestly
that's your theory i like that theory oh
that's my theory that is that your
theory
because that's all for yourself that's
my theory man
this is our first time doing it together
and you don't know yet but i go for the
bat crazy theory
okay so let's think about that
realistically if they did do a bunch of
drugs and just coasted that drug wave
of course they would of course why
wouldn't they they're the
internals they're not like the sometimes
they're not like the oh i'm gonna
overdose at the viper room like river
phoenix they're
forever they can live through anything
and so if
yeah they can live through everything
and if they're all playing a different
part as being like different people
in whatever this universe it's like one
of them is going to be the drug addict
not like a drug addict but one of them
is going to be like the party or the
like whoo
oh they're tied to greek gods and
goddesses baby you know that they party
you know that they do you live long
enough you're gonna be the most stressed
out person in the world one hundred
percent
yeah or you're gonna turn into a vampire
and take a nap which is what happened
so you either like go nuts or you
quaalude out
way too soon
i'm very into this this child is leading
the pool right now this child is making
the laughs this is the michael phelps
right here
here is a road theory as to where the
eternals could potentially be
um i think that they could have gone
into space
it's very possible because like the
origins of the eternals
um at least some factions of the
eternals anyway they do go off into
space which is why we have thanos uh
down the line because
thanos is into on titan and then we have
people that uh
went to uranus if i not like the planets
ha not your ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha i'm
not laughing
i'm the first person to ever make that
joke so you guys need to give your
friends
the first person ever like that yeah
like no one's made the connection
between uranus
and the uh the rectal region honestly
it's it's uh it's a gift really i'm a
comedy legend they tell me i don't know
what i'm saying anyway
um i hate you keep going i hate myself
um don't say that but me and my
therapist are working on that one oh i'm
just kidding
where are we going where are we going um
but anyway
no the internals could have went off
into space for some type of
mission or to like to reconnell and
colonize
or like it's it's possible we never know
but like
i think i like tommy's idea because i
think there's
comic precedent for um memory wipes or
like
having amnesia be like i don't remember
that i'm actually this amazing person
um so yeah they're probably just
chilling
um so actually to piggyback off of the
space
theory going into space okay uh this
is kind of like a maybe like a other
part of the movie situation
not why they like where they've been but
because feige said that this movie is
gonna be taking place over
seven thousand years is that what he
said i think it was seven thousand
um the beginning of that timeline
could have been like millions of years
ago
around when like odin what before odin
was born when it was the first kings of
asgard
yes and so i wonder if we're gonna see
some of
those origins in this just speaking of
space you know
oh my gosh so i'm kind of i'm kind of
interested to see
all of the like pre-dating stuff yeah
we're gonna see like what they were
involved
in okay number one still leading number
one still leading
okay tommy all the eternals are lining
up and they're like
it's right before uh the end of um
infinity war and they're like
we gotta help these people we gotta help
them but we gotta help them they're all
running to help out right as the snap
ends and they all
dusted every single oh my god
colonel dusted
across the board dusting but they're
like it's a huge action scene it's like
when samuel
jackson and the rock jump off the roof
in uh and uh wasn't with the other guys
the feral mark where they're like yeah
are you ready to do this and you think
they're gonna be the hero
the movie and then they jump off and
they got dusted
yeah i think that makes a lot of sense
because like thanos would probably do
that if you think about it because like
if i'm thanos and i know about you know
the eternals and the deviants because he
is
a deviant i'm gonna be like well if i'm
gonna snap i'm going to make sure i'm
going to snap
all the powerful people that i know and
i can probably try to undo the snap
so do you think that thanos did some
like some focused snapping there
like you think that he's specifically if
anyone
there's been a little talk around these
parts about possibly a younger
version of thanos showing up because
because he is you know deviant
and i'm wondering uh what do you guys
think a or b
do you think that young thanos is gonna
be more like young sheldon or do you
think he's gonna be more like young
dumbledore
because he's hella gonna be young
he has to be young dumbledore i agree i
want dumbles
still married by josh like like how
how jim parsons narrates young sheldon i
still want josh brolin to narrate over
whoever plays
oh same i wanted to be i wanted to be
josh brolin but i want him to look like
like a like baby grimace because then we
could get
the mcdonald's cinematic universe
involved you know
like the the mdcu in the mcu
a little like crossover whitney you need
those just like baby grooves you
already won this category you don't need
to
i really want to see the um thanos's
birth
because like in the comments they know
his mom tries to kill him at birth
because she's just like something's not
right with this baby
i gotta get rid of this baby he looks
like a happy meal toy kill him with fire
do you think we'll be seeing if we did
get the birth of
thanos do you think we'd be getting star
fox oh yeah for sure
do you think like star fox well i mean
starbucks would have to be in
so you think we'd get like everyone uh
who was spanish's mom
it's sue yeah yeah so we'd get like
you think we'd get since we're getting
eternals i mean it makes sense that
celestials would come into the narrative
do you think the battle is going to be
between the eternals and celestials or
do you think it's going to be the
eternals trying to bring back
all the wrong that they did or trying to
make up for all the wrong that they did
this entire time
i think that there's there's one aspect
of the celestials that you know is
really important
um it's the celestial host where the
celestials come back and they check up
on their um
scientific experiments and so that is a
really big deal because that could
potentially be an apocalyptic event
but if you don't pass you know the the
test then the earth is going to be
destroyed and like they're gonna
restart their experiments so uh the
eternals could potentially be
trying to fight that it's like they're
sort of galactus
type villain um like the fantastic four
wood and like they're just trying to
face off with these titans and trying to
stop them from
from hurting um the planet that makes
sense that makes sense
who knows we only got literally
cumulative cumulative cumulative big
word for jessica to say
um we only got like 10 seconds of
eternals
and we're trying to piece with like what
gemma chan said we're like
okay she said it's up to them we see
camille dressed like
a a butthole so we think there's so many
theories so we think their minds got
wiped
we think we're going prehistoric
prehistoric we're going back we're back
dating the time of when they originally
showed up
and we i'm going through your guys's
theories of what we put hopefully
yes we have so many ideas i thought we
already decided who wanted
no i'm going to shut up i'm going
through
i'm going through i like a mind wipe
because they do do that
and then it's also easier to be like and
it would be so much fun
to see what they're doing on earth or in
space
either way and be like what do you mean
i'm cersei i was like what do you mean
i my brother or my uncle like thanos
like what was the guy that snapped
no no no no so if there's like if it's
that mind wipe
kind of sort of situation i like that
but the idea of actually back dating and
going through timeline and like
mirroring that of like greek mythology
or just religion in general
of how like odin came to be and how thor
and them are basically nothing compared
to what this is and then also
uh thor's mom would be involved right
yes and also i totally forgot to say
this
but i think that we might
be seeing some types of tie-ins that
could either be a sort of set up for dr
strange maybe like the next doctor
strange or somehow tie into the dr
strange universe and the mystic arts
because it's between dimensions
and all that and i think that it's
possible that the eternals might be
trying to
connect with some of that mystic
cosmic juju that's out there to go into
the multiverse would be
i'm a very big fan of it so i really
love that you said that because just
last night i think that i was like oh my
god like the eternals means we might see
the ancient one again and i was so
excited
i think we could i don't know i'm also
like i was that person that was like oh
one division we're gonna get reed
richards i was like oh they're coming
here
so i was like i'm not a good person when
it comes to theories
though i'm hosting this rogue theory i
don't know as a host yeah there's
possibility as jessica clements not a
host
i don't know i don't think
i that's asking for too much uh marvel's
like slow your role maybe we'll get like
a glimpse
of how we saw like in one division how
we saw wanda like
her full like when she was in i forgot
where
she was but she saw herself or what
could
people like yeah yeah we might see
something of that and be like oh who's
this and it's like it's the ancient one
or oh we're gonna see the one above all
and it's like okay
maybe um i am excited this but that it
can't connect to the multiverse though
and then we'll get into that
i also like predating it if we go
through the timeline we could see
apocalypse technically
if we're gonna actually involve x-men um
i think there's a lot of possibilities
so yeah i did declare the winner already
but i've gotta say the winner
is whitney van landingham whitney i'm
giving you
i'm giving you i'm giving you one
let's imagine these as golden tickets um
because
when voss said i was hosting he
so you get two two and a half of these
yay one and a half tommy
yeah and a half tommy i loved your
theory
so i'm going to give you two pairs of
glasses
two pairs of glasses and empty you get
nothing
uh empty
i'm giving empty for coming through with
the actual backing up our theories i'm
gonna give you two
i'm gonna give you two glasses as well
i'm gonna give you two glasses
i like to help my friends out you know
oh sorry guys
two friends sweet boy two two and two
and a half you guys so
we've got some thoughts about some other
mcu films that are coming through we
just talked about eternals
and now we're gonna get into the marbles
but before we get into marbles we have
to get into our ads that make it so
possible for us to do rogue theory every
week starting with who says taking care
of your life needs to be hard
what's great about cbd is that it helps
you feel better without making drastic
changes to your routine i mean here at
new rockstars eric vos uses it to help
him with pain
and soreness after exercise because this
man has been going way too ham
during fitness origins but a hard
working man anyway caliper cbd powder is
the only clinically proven
fast-acting cbd caliber gives you the
benefits
of cbd in just 10 minutes cbd oils can
take up to two hours to fully absorb
which is way longer than you want to
wait i don't want to wait two hours the
great thing about calipers little powder
packets is that they're mobile
so that you can take them to work or on
the road you can pop one into your
morning tea
or your afternoon smoothie or your
evening tea your smoothie i'm not
telling you when to
drink your teas it's up to you um it's
all natural
vegan free of fillers added chemicals
and artificial flavors
get 20 off your first order when you use
promo code
rogue at tricaliper.com
rogue you can try caliper cbd risk free
for 30 days if you don't love it
they'll give you a full refund a full
refund so that's tricaliper.com
rogue don't forget the promo code rogue
for 20 off
your first order okay okay most of us
have very little choice in internet
service provider
because isps operate like monopolies in
the regions they serve
they use this monopoly power to take
advantage of customers with data caps
and streaming throttles it's
the worst we all have it uh worst of all
many of the isps
log your internet activity and sell the
data on the other on to other big tech
companies or advertisers
to prevent isps from seeing my internet
activity
i protect my devices with expressvpn
it's an app for your computer or
smartphone that encrypts all your
network data and tunnels it through a
secure vpn server
expressvpn is the best way to hide your
online activity from your isp
just download the app tap one button and
you're protected and expressvpn does all
of this without slowing your internet
connection
you hear that jessica it'll stop slowing
down your internet connection
i'm talking to myself in third person
either way that's why it's rated number
one vpn
service by cnet wired so stop handing
over your personal data to isps and
other tech giants who mine
your activity and sell off your
information protect yourself with the
vpn i trust to keep me private online
visit expressvpn.com rogue that's
express
vpn e x p r e s s
v p n dot com slash rogue to get these
three extra months for free go to
expressvpn.com
rogue now to learn more so you guys
well we got so much stuff in those those
clips
we got almost too much stuff and i know
you guys are probably like oh they're
gonna talk about this they're gonna talk
about that but we're gonna talk about
the marvel's plot
right now so the same announcement video
showed us the title for captain marvel
sequel for the first time the marvels
besides this being very on brand for the
marvel comics con
company what else could this new title
mean for the plot and the sequel
of the the plot of the sequel so what
could it mean
and who are we gonna see coming back or
who we're going to see in general
go ahead woo me children i mean from the
logo
it seems that we're obviously i mean
it's captain marvel 2 so we're going to
get
carol danvers and we also got a
spectrum's logo on there right in this
middle on the a um and then we have um
for the s the uh kamala khan miss marvel
logo so we're gonna get all three of
them so they're gonna be
in there obviously but for returning
people
um i mean maybe we'll get woo again i'm
a big fan of the woo
oh yeah hashtag whoopties out there
um that's what i call the uh supporters
the whoopties
oh no but yeah i don't know like what do
you guys think this uh this movie's
gonna be about
here's some ideas what if it's just it's
a jetson's revival
meet the marbles that's what it is
and uh instead of the instead of the dog
we have the flurkin we have goose
and uh that's that's what i think i hope
so you know what's
that editors animation 30 minutes please
please uh just it's just gonna be
carol kamala and monica
and they're just gonna have their own
little jetsons his family
family models well luckily
we might not get the jetsons
unfortunately
hopefully the flintstones but the last
time that we did see
monica was in one division where she was
approached by
the scroll right to go back up in space
or they pointed out back up to space to
go see
uh nick fury so with that being said i
guess if they're going up to space
that i'm trying to connect where
we see so monica's going to be in
marvels uh we also got kamala gonna be
in marbles but we don't know much about
the marvel series
the miss marvel series but for monica
she's going up to space
all right is carol danvers already there
i think i think she's uh
she's with uh jude law right now that's
my theory
i think john wrong is out here plotting
this man he got
way too like he felt disrespected at the
end of captain marvel and he's just like
yo
and like the cree from what i can tell
the cree in the comics anyway and like
the cree and the mcu
they're not very like you know chill
people when it comes to failure it's
just like
yeah no we could see pieces of eternals
in it but i don't think we
would unless it has to do with the x-men
gene which i don't think we're going to
get into in eternals
um i think we're going to get into the
idea of
you know bodies being manipulated by
cosmic elements because that's what
yeah they all have in common because we
have carol who's manipulated by the
the engine in captain marvel and then we
have um
spectrum through the events of juan
division and
wanda's um reality energy um
and then we have uh miss marvel who is
going to
i we're definitely not going to go the
inhumans route here because i think
kevin feige is like what if humans that
never happened
look away um like we don't say the i
word here um
but yeah i think that that's probably
gonna be
um a main core and like i feel like that
would make sense if the rumors are true
that um michael korvac is going to be
involved
with um with in in this plot
because quarterback is a very uh he's a
very powerful person
and he's no he's no slouch
yeah he's uh he's he's had his run-ins
with cosmic energy in the past so like
that could be that way okay but um okay
i don't know
we'll see it's interesting to hear what
you think the villain would i guess the
pov of like
who we would be seeing in there that are
not entirely great
not entirely not entirely great i
completely just thought they were gonna
go
the they're gonna have to like we're
gonna get ready or wrap
up i need to get better at the timeline
if i'm hosting these for secret invasion
um because i feel like she's just going
to be dealing with only matters in space
and i i feel like that's carol dan
versus thing is also just like i'm not
going to really be on earth unless they
really need me so that's why they're
sending
miss marvel and uh monica up there but
this is not a show for my theories i'm
so sorry i just realized that i'm like
conversation it's a conversation we're
all about to talk man
the hardest part about being a host for
this is not putting in your two cents
that's like the hardest to hear your two
cents
all your sense your 25 cents your 10
cents everything everybody gets listen i
have
copious amounts of student debt i will
take any sense that you have okay
what are you talking about i forgot that
you live at the ymca tommy and whitney
feel free to chime in
before me and me and mt just keep making
jokes about how
poor we are i don't i this was a hard
one i don't really have a good option
for this one i don't know i don't know
anything about the uh
we need all these movies to come out
before we can theorize about yeah it's
coming out in four years or three years
so exactly that is true but the one the
one kind of
thing okay so this is obviously just a
theory i don't know if this is gonna be
a thing or not
but something that we have seen in the
past with
like sequels that marvel does is that
the sequel
is usually that hero uh like
struggling with like losing their powers
or their powers
waning or having to find new control
and so i know that we already kind of
covered this uh with the eternals and
stuff but
i do think that there's a possibility
that carol danvers could be struggling
through like a power change or like a
power
depletion of some kind um in the
aftermath
of everything that happened with
infinity war because like it'd be a good
way to like de-power her for a little
bit so she
so we can see her struggle and then like
yeah i know i'm great again hooray
yeah um i think that'd be kind of fun to
see so yeah
that's what i'm hoping for little
thingies crossed we've got
we've got uh second uh timeline gamora
out there struggling with your identity
yeah you need some guidance from uh from
the marvels
uh we have you know the guardians could
always come in and cameo
oh no i think they're setting up the um
incursions i think we're going to get
some type of well during this scenario i
want to
secret
i have been talking about secret wars
since the day i was born
i'm like it's going to happen i've i've
pitched rogue theories about it like 20
times
i always bring back into secret wars i
love secret wars i want it to i just
don't think it's gonna be
now i think it's gonna be like look at
the highest people we can get to
we're trying to not like if this is
improv we're not trying to stay grounded
so we're like we're gonna deal with
actual heaven and hell now we're going
to deal with heaven and hell we're going
to deal with science we're going to deal
with like
space or not space uh magic so i think
we're saying so we're not staying
grounded at all and then we're going to
get grounded and come back
with secret wars i think it's a good way
to go back to something bigger
than literally those celestials and
eternals
but staying small because it's like oh
we're gonna have everybody fight each
other
villains and good and i'm like
i have been yelling from the heavens for
secret wars
sorry i love it when they first said
secret invasion i thought they said
secret wars and i went
and i freaked out and then they were
like no it's secret invasion and i was
like
okay i guess that makes sense also do
you think we could get with
marvel's do you think we could just get
another kind of buddy cop scenario that
we got with doctor that's what i want
that is yeah ideally what i want like
it's just
like maybe carol danvers can't fight
alone and so that's why they're sending
photon and um and miss marvel
uh a child uh a smart child yeah
a child a literal child but i'm not
saying that she's not worthy but
we could be getting that scenario where
they're cleaning up like a heavier thing
in space
um their favorite thing to do is to
split it off into weird
scenarios where it's like oh doctor
strange can't fight this but you could
fight this
uh and so
[Laughter]
i hate when they do that i was getting
so mad in one division because everyone
was like why is it
doctor strange there yet and i'm like
because it's not a level threat for
doctor strange they all have different
threat levels
yeah man dr strange doesn't care about a
small town
he said forget about it forget about it
all right you guys
we uh don't want to say it but i'm gonna
say
we're all just waiting for the marvels
we're waiting to see what more comes
through we're trying to figure out more
what's happening in space
and that way we can which is we are very
new to this the the
this came out yesterday and we're
literally like
let's pull out what we think is coming
and there's a lot of little tidbits in
the poster but
not much we can
completely theorize but with that being
said
other than my theory which was great
give yourself the points
so i'm gonna give you i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you
two whitney two of these
[Music]
i'm gonna give you one pairs of glasses
thank you and i actually broke my
glasses so i
would i would like some more baby oh my
gosh
this is how i drive now um tommy because
you're so cute i'm giving you one lip
gloss
oh you know i gotta love i gotta love
i gotta love my boy so whitney is still
in the league but now we're getting
in the lead but now we're getting into
the real questions which is all
improvised
and i can't wait to hear your guys's
very good and
funny answers you never know what's
gonna happen you never know you never
know
you never know what's going to happen
okay vin diesel said in an interview
this week that they audition the cars
they use in fast and the furious movies
give me your best impression of a car
auditioning for a fast and furious movie
ah jeez who do i impress more helen
mirren ludacris helen mirren ludacris
helen mirren
that's a good car that's a good car
hopefully it knows helen mirren
okay baby all right uh hi my name is
ford fiesta
i i'm here to audition for the role of
uh
carr i am willing to shave i'm located
in los angeles and i am a proud member
of sag-aftra
okay should i just go or do you want to
queue me in
okay just go
just late family
was that good i could do another one no
no
[Music]
no he nailed the whole auditioning field
i felt like
yeah i felt like i was scared i felt
like i was part of the family
you know like i felt like i was gonna
ride forever
i'm giving you that point tommy i i i
like i'm giving you that yeah i feel
like this is what
paul walker would have wanted it is it
is what paul walker would have wanted
this this audition for our car so last
last real question
that's one point for tommy ding ding the
writer and director of the leprechaun
movies if you guys remember that
great flicks yes and the one with
jennifer aniston
absolutely a series mentioned this week
that they had developed a vampire
crossover series called
vampercon you heard it's leprechaun and
vampire put together a vampire
con what other mythical creature would
you want to see turned into a vampire
that sounds like a a vampire convention
it does vampire
yeah it does it does it does for sure
sounds like you could meet all of the
half
vampire half others at pampercon they're
and they fight they have a turf war
oh i was thinking it was more like a
like a big old
tinder matchup just all of them getting
at it
trying to make other weird little messed
up babies
interesting i love it i've got a real
answer here i take this very seriously
as you know
for me it would be simply a vampire
umpire crossover a vampire
and that way when you're at the game and
you go you suck
umpire the vampire would turn around and
go that's right
tommy i hate how much in love with you
um perfect i i
it's perfect i'd have nothing else to
say to that okay you too come on
that's nice that's so great okay um
what other mythical creature i think
it'd be really cool to see
a unicorn uh vampire
um i don't know how that would work do
they stab them with the horns
unicorn or more vampire i think we're
gonna say it's mostly it's more
unicorn than vampire because unicorns
are great on their own but like they
just fly around looking for their
victims and they're like
oh my god look it's a unicorn that's how
they trick you they just fly down
they're like oh you're excited for me
right and then they bite your neck
and then a horse that's a really scary
thing it's like seeing a pegasus and
then it bites you in the face
yeah or the neck yeah that's a
horrifying one i don't like the idea of
that i'm afraid of horses though you
guys
legitimately me too they're huge oh
shame they're dude i hate horses
thank you oh my god you're literally the
worst
whitney you're about to get this point
damn it whitney you're about to get this
damn wow she's sucking up to the host
i'm only allergic to horses and then and
by coincidence
i've never had to come across one
because i'm terrified of them yeah when
i was when i was 10 years old my mom
made me go backpacking and they made me
ride a horse up a
mountain and it got spooked while we
were near a cliff
crossing a gosh dang waterfall and it
tried to
buck me off a waterfall i was ten i have
never messed with a horse
again and i never will they are awful i
hate them they're covered in flies
also their shoes are like so not cute
you know like they're covered in flies
them off they're covered in flats my
favorite part
brush your ponytail it's it's it's gross
like stop it
oh my gosh the horse hates i love this
so great i love it i'm here for it uh
every horse girl watching this is like
okay seriously you know what i'm going
to write them both letters
right now everything's
a little creature be vampire horse girl
oh my god
is that what yours is that you're wait
i'm
i'm torn between vampire horse girl and
uh i was i was gonna say vampire tony
the tiger
oh my god i just wanna see that
so bad
they're more than good they're covered
in dinner you know
in dna
wow oh y'all i'm so sorry
y'all i am so sorry but whitney gets
that damn
that would have been great if we chose
mass serial mascots
with any vampire i would have smackums
the frog but also
horrifying dude
yeah he's like yeah yeah count chocula
is just like you guys are this is
this is vampire appropriation
i'm mad out of my coffin you're not even
really dead
they're going the toucan sam is just
flying over him with my
teeth oh my god that'd be so cool
i get it i get it it's not like it used
to be in the graveyard no it's yeah it's
not like
it used to be there goes the
neighborhood
oh my god and all this serial mascots
are grave robbers that
just takes it up a level every single
one so you have to find new houses now
that they're vampires
poor boss he's going to watch this and
be like you guys didn't talk about
the idiot you didn't talk about anything
you guys were supposed to talk about
marvel guys like what's a marvel what
all i know is the vampire tiger was part
of the mcu
so get over it last time i checked
smackems was a vampire
so you guys
you guys let's go over these point
scores and again
as the host of new rockstars rogue
theory i go for them crazy ass
theories is whitney
we haven't done this in a minute but it
was my favorite part
of rogue theory you get one wish you can
what what's your wish
we haven't done this in a minute and i
don't know why we took it away
i made everybody say happy birthday to
me once but you can do something
you know that makes more sense yeah i
don't i i mean yeah i don't expect you
to
to help me find my greatest witch which
is uh who
is going to be the next eligible
bachelorette for bill gates biggest
question on my mind right now
uh i i think it's going to be either the
queen or boris johnson personally
but uh you gotta go for boris it's
definitely gotta be boring
what do i want to wish for okay
can i have the wish can all of you guys
impersonate pugsley really quick for me
oh my god look at this he's my
biological child watch
save that for when the cameras are
rolling
how do i do it this is like big eyes
yeah big guys big eyes big snoring he
looks wor
he looks worried he looks very weird
i can't do it yes perfect perfect
perfect okay just got it
jessica's got it with the lower lip
concern
this is how i flirt with women
did you just blow up the moon because
you look like a cartoon
[Laughter]
i'd be into it i'd be like i'm going to
buy him a drink
watch out it really does it's a real
panty dropper nope don't put that in
anyway
he's stealing moms and he's dropping
panties
all right you guys that was new
rockstars rogue theory
uh thank you mt thank you for tommy
thank you whitney for
coming yes and you can follow me at lulu
underscore clemens on twitter
luluclemons everything else team jacob
on twitch
um and yeah go support our channel go
supporting the rockstars
like comment subscribe buy the new merch
at rockstarsmerch.com
and i guess see you guys next time on
rogue theory
take it easy everybody
[Music]
you